[Musik]
was halten sie von Friedrich Merz als
Kanzlerkandidat die Diskussion die
stellt sich ja über noch gar keine gfage
aber sie lachen sch ja vielleicht stellt
erübrigt sich die Frage altersbedingt
irgendwann ich glaube viele können sich
nicht vorstellen aber ein bisschen Zeit
bis sich die Frage final stellt ist ja
noch also sie hoffen einfach dass ich
das durches Alter
erledigt Junge Union ist wenigstens
ehrlich ich gut erfrischend selbst die
Hälfte aller cduwähler als kanzlerkaten
schlecht interessant interessant wir
haben tatsächlich mal eine KI gefragt
wie Friedrich mer sympathischer werden
könnte auch für Frauen hier so schön mit
Gitarre was davon ist okay ja Lagerfeuer
aber ich w jetzt nicht so auf de Date
aus insofern son hätte ich mir auch
Sorgen
gemacht was halten Sie denn von einem
Kanzlerkandidaten Friedrich Merz kann
dazu nicht kan dazu nicht sagen meine
Freunde Vorstand glauben Sie denn dass
friich der richtiger als Kanzlerkandidat
ist
ich glaube das muss die Mehrheit
entscheiden für mich persönlich nicht
aber wenn die mehrhe nein hätte auch
gereicht wer wäre denn besserer
Kanzlerkandidat
als sehr schnell Lindemann Lindemann
gilt ja als der junge Friedrich März
nein überhaupt nicht er ist viel toller
und Henrik büst ist ein sehr
sympathischer junger Familienvater das
spricht natürlich glaube ich Frauen noch
ein bisschen mehr wir sammeln heute
Grußworte für den Kanzler Wahlkampf von
hendri W
hier dem Termin hallo guten Tag hallo
mal gerade zu dem Termin den ich habe
ich freue mich immer sie zu sehen vor
allem allerdings wenn sie mit anderen
die Interviews
fen so kommen wir nicht weiter Friedrich
März braucht von den jungen Leuten hier
jetzt mal ein paar fresche Ideen ja man
glaubt es komm aber ich stehe hier
tatsächlich mit dem einzigen CDU tiktok
Star na ja also wir haben ganz gut
gearbeitet schon bezeichnet dass sie der
CDU tiktok Star sind ja da kann man
wieder sehen tiktok hat nichts mit dem
Alter zu tun ne man muss sich nur in
diese Geschichte reinbegeben und
authentisch bleiben sollte einfach mal
sich an ihn beis so kleines tanzvide
einfach mal als Beispiel ein paar
provozierende Sprüche hat er ja heute
auch gebracht und dann
läuft also natürlich sind die meisten
hier bei der Jungen Union doch März Fans
aber ich bin froh dass ich wenigstens
ein gefunden habe der gemeinsam mit mir
über den Friedrich
lacht als Kanzlerkandidat was wäre das
Gute daran abgesehen davon dass sie es
dann nicht geworden sind dass Olaf
Scholz nicht mehr Kanzler ist ist nicht
Friedrich Merz die einzige Chance als
für Olaf Scholz überhaupt noch kanzer zu
bleiben nein also der Bundeskanzler
selber ist
ja ein großartiger
Redner ein witziger Charmeur und er
findet ja er findet auch immer sein Weg
wie ich letzt gesehen habe er läuft vom
roten Teppich irgendwo vorbei an seinen
staatsgesten ich Friedrich Merz zum
Glück gar nicht dass er in Fettnäppchen
tritt ne nein überup
wie W sie geben mir ein Interview und
ich besorge
Zahnarzttermin ich GL einfach dass er
nicht so sympathisch ist wie manch
andere vom Herzen bestimmt schon aber es
kann er nicht so gut zeigen vielleicht
mal Tipp an ihn um das mehr zu zeigen
einfach bisschen cooler werden ja ich
glaub ne das wird nich schade fest steht
ein die CDU braucht einen
Kanzlerkandidaten jemand der präsent ist
konservativ und sich nicht den Mund
verbieten lässt aber könnte das
[Musik]
sein hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den
Kanal abonnieren er deutet nach unten in
die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen
[Musik]
Dank